- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our Daily Homeroom live stream.
The whole goal of this is for all of us
to stay connected during
times of school closures.
Depending on the day,
this is a time for all of y'all
to ask questions of myself
or other guests or team members
we might have at Khan Academy.
It might be about navigating
school, the school closures,
how to learn a subject
or frankly, whatever
y'all wanna ask about.
So feel free if you're
on YouTube or Facebook
or some other social media channel,
start asking questions
in the message boards.
We have team members who are
looking at those questions
and then surfacing to them.
To me on a little doc
that I have on the screen right over here.
I also have my colleague Dan,
who's going to be jumping in
and help surface questions.
And then the other interesting things
that y'all might post.
Hey Dan.
And just as a reminder, Khan
Academy is a not-for-profit.
We have a mission of providing
a free world class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And as you can imagine we
could have never foreseen
this COVID-19 crisis, the school closures,
but we think it's our duty given
what we've been building
over the last decade
and the resources we have available
and given our mission
to really try to step up
as much as we can in this time.
So we've been trying to
put all of the resources
that we have from Pre-K all
the way through high school
and college together,
so it can be coherent for
parents, teachers and students.
We've been putting together learning plans
and schedules and webinars for all of you
and we've been doing this live stream.
We are funded by philanthropic
donations from folks like
yourself and that becoming
increasingly vocal,
to telling folks that we've
been running at a deficit
even before the crisis hit
and our costs are going up
and there's more that we want
to do because of the crisis,
so that we can accelerate hopefully over
the course of the summer and
this coming back to school.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
I want to give a special shout out to
in the last several weeks,
Bank of America followed
by AT&T, Google.org and
Novartis and we need more help.
If you're representing a corporation
please think about donating Khan Academy.
Donating to Khan Academy in
this time obviously people
are thinking about the virus,
they thing about mental health,
they thing about the economy,
but how do we keep kids
learning especially
the kids most in need
who might not have access
to other supports.
I think is, is a, is a
really, really key question
and we want to help where we can.
So with that, I'm happy to
start answering some questions
that we have here.
So let's see the first question I have
and I have to say, Susanna
Garcia Domingo says
you are a regular at asking questions.
I guess good questions.
These are the ones I get surface.
There are no bad questions,
but from YouTube, Susana asks,
"Hi Sal, what was your
last most memorable meal?
Please describe that experience?"
It's an interesting question.
And my last most memorable
meal, you know what it was,
it was thanksgiving like
four or five years ago.
And I had the idea to not eat
to fast before thanksgiving.
And I have to say when
you, when you fast for,
I think I had fasted for 36 hours,
kids don't do this at home,
you consult your doctor
and things like that,
but I find every now and then
you know, just a water fast.
So I was drinking water.
It kind of gets your sensory acuity up.
And so going into that
thanksgiving I had a cheesecake
and it was the best cheesecake I ever had.
I think it was a good cheesecake
and I hadn't eaten for
a long period of time.
So yeah, that was the most memorable meal.
But anyway, no dietary advice.
Please don't go fast
without medical supervision,
standard disclaimers.
- Sal, so we wanted to do something
a little bit different today.
We get a lot of amazing
questions on this forum,
but we also get amazing
posts in social media.
So we thought we'd share a
few with our audience today.
So the first one is from YouTube
comment from Kerpal Singh,
she says, or he says, "I
give a roll of toilet paper
to Salman Khan any day.
Thank you Kerpal, I hope
one day we get a chance
to I guess share toilet paper.
That's a little, yeah,
actually I've been getting
a lot of toilet paper offers lately,
which I think 'cause it is
like the new gold I guess.
And I just want to let everyone know
that you know, my family, we
consider ourselves fortunate.
We have I think at least
a solid two weeks supply
of toilet paper at home.
So we're doing good, no
need to worry about that.
- Great, and then we have
a question on YouTube
from Rashida Idris.
"How many hours should an
eighth grader study a day?"
How many hours should an
eighth grader study a day?
So I think there's kind of a
minimum I think in anything,
if you want to get better at
it's good to build a habit
to do a little bit every day.
And so I would say if your eighth grader,
especially in times of school closures,
if you could put in even a
solid focused 30 minutes in each
of the subjects that you want
to make solid progress in,
you're going to be in great shape
when you go back to school in the fall.
So I would put in at least 30
minutes a day on Khan Academy
and you could take a break on weekends.
But Monday through Friday,
try to put at least 30
minutes a day in Khan Academy,
I would do at least 30 minutes on math.
I would do 30 minutes a day
of reading of some form.
Find some books that are at your level
that you would really enjoy reading
and read them for at
least 30 minutes a day.
And hopefully longer than that
if you really enjoy the book.
And I would do at least 30
minutes a day of trying to write
and you know, it might
be a little bit longer.
It could be as simple as journaling.
It could be there's a
lot of stuff going on
in the world today.
Write opinion pieces, create a blog,
share it with and family.
I think if you do those three things,
you're going to be in decent shape.
And then if you feel like
you have that under control
and you're able to do other
things like go outside
and run and spend time with your family
and take on some fun projects
that you've always wanted to do,
then you could layer on a little bit more.
You could maybe do another
30 minutes a day of science
or and Khan Academy has
a lot of resources there.
We don't have as much as we'd like
at the middle school level yet.
But if you are looking to keep going,
I think you could definitely look at
some of the beginning
units of our biology,
high school biology,
high school chemistry,
and even some of the things
on things like Newton's laws and physics.
You can start getting a leg up.
And so I would say that
that would be a good,
if you're able to do it consistently,
that'd be a good amount of
learning on a daily basis.
Now obviously you could do
more, but I would just say,
that's great, but just
don't stress yourself out.
This is a time where we should make sure
that we're taking care of ourselves
and having time to run outside and play
and spend time with family as well.
So there's a, this is a
good question from YouTube,
Elliot H who refers to
me as Dumbledore Sal
and I enjoy that.
That was part of my
motivation for growing a beard
that hopefully someone would
one day see the resemblance.
"When is it better to innovate
through business example,
"Apple, Google or Tesla rather
than through philanthropy,
"example, Khan Academy, Wikipedia?
"You judge that a free
world class education
"would be better achieved
philanthropically.
"What is the more meaningful innovations
"happen better through business?"
That is a very, very
good question, Elliot.
So the way I think about it, I
do believe generally speaking
in market forces in capitalism.
And so I think generally free enterprise
and I guess you could
say the profit motive
when markets function well
I can create a lot of innovation.
And some of those things that you know,
the Googles of the world,
the Teslas, the Apples,
and you can, you can
think of many, many others
where people deployed capital
and a place where they thought
that they could create something
of value to other people.
People were willing to pay for that value
that created a return on the capital
and more money to invest in that effort.
So that's great.
And I actually think rightfully
that is most of our economy.
But I think there are
segments of our economy
where either the markets for some reason
aren't working well.
And there's many reasons
why markets sometimes
don't work well.
There might be externalities
to what the market is capturing
that aren't captured in the price.
And you know, people think
about some of those things
in terms of pollution
and things like that.
There's markets where there
isn't transparent information.
There's markets where
the buyers, the sellers
and the beneficiaries
are different people.
So you don't get that same accountability
that you would have in a
traditional marketplace.
And there's situations
where the market might work,
but what it does work,
it leads to outcomes
aren't consistent with our values.
And I would say the two areas
where it's not wholesale.
You know, there's
definitely a lot of space
for profits in education
and in healthcare.
But those are the two
areas where I would say,
markets sometimes get a little bit
kind of fall into that gray area.
I think we as a society
have a value system
that if someone wants to learn,
they should be able to learn regardless
of their parents' income
or what neighborhood they grow up in.
And if someone is bleeding
or dying that we should treat them,
we should treat them first
before thinking about
their ability to pay.
I think those are two universal
values that we all have.
And sometimes markets aren't
able to make that happen.
Now somewhat argue that
that's the role of government
that government can play those roles
but where I see the philanthropic
sector being valuable
is that gap of sometimes government
is a little bit slow
to move into something
they may be not, can't innovate as fast.
And then on the for profit
side, they can innovate fast,
but sometimes the motivations
aren't completely aligned
with the value system.
And so that's where I think
a philanthropic of sector
is really valuable.
And you know, Khan Academy in theory
could have been a for profit company.
In fact, in the early days,
some of the first folks I talked to
were investors who was like,
"Hey, we can make this a real thing."
The conversations around
how do you monetize it?
Oh, we could give this stuff for free.
But then we would have
to charge for that stuff.
That felt a little bit
inconsistent with at least
what I was hoping Khan
Academy could become.
And when I looked through the world
and history of institutions
that had been able to serve many millions
or hundreds of millions
or billions of people
and have been able to
do it over generations.
So not just that first 20 or 30 years
where you might have that founding team
that wants to operate in a certain way,
but over many, many, many generations.
It's consistently, it's nonprofits.
I think even some of the great for-profits
that we know today, history would tell us
that in 30 or 40 or 50 years,
they'll probably be very,
very different organizations
than they are right now.
While many of the not-for-profits
have a little bit more
of a strong narrative
over multiple generations,
and it was delusional
when someone operating
out of a walk in closet.
but I do hope increasingly
and I'm more open about it,
that Khan Academy goes well beyond me.
And that in a hundred years,
folks around the planet
are like, of course access to
a free world class education
for anyone anywhere is there.
And who knows what kind of
Academy looks like then,
it might be some type of
virtual reality experience.
It might be a pill you
take all of a sudden,
you know, a lot of things who
knows that was the thinking.
- Sal, we have a question
on YouTube from a teacher,
Schendel red queen of Wonderland asked,
"Mr. Khan, do you have
any advice for leadership?
"I've been trying to host
Zoom meetings with my classes
"and I find it really difficult to do so."
- So Schendel I'm assuming when you say
you've been trying to
advice for leadership
with your classes, I'm
assuming you're talking about
like as kind of teaching or
teaching virtually, although,
I could give my two cents on
leadership generally although
I'm sure many of the
Khan Academy team members
might roll their eyes.
(laughs)
I'm sure they have a better sense of
how effective my leadership is or not.
But you know, if you're
teaching virtually,
and I have been working
with several teachers here
and I've been doing a
few myself volunteering
trying to teach virtually,
it actually takes me back to 2004
when I was tutoring my cousins
and we didn't have Zoom back then,
we didn't have Google Hangouts back then,
but I was trying to use the phone
and we had some tablet software
that we could see each other's writing.
And what I found is
the more virtual it is,
the more that you have to
really drive interaction.
So I've run a couple of sessions
along with some teachers
in a school district and
out here in California,
and what we're all trying to do is,
you know, put up a problem,
just an example problem,
it doesn't have to be a
super structured lesson
but you put up an example problem
could just be on a white board.
If you have a digital tablet,
you can share your screen
and then you say,
"Okay, who has some
ideas on the first step?"
And so the more, and then
even cold call people like,
"Hey Michael, what do you
think is the next step?"
And so I think the more that you can get
that inter that exchange the better
and the more engaging it's going to be,
especially if you're doing
it on a modality like Zoom.
What what I say is, if
it's just me lecturing
the whole time, that's so
different than a video.
So there's no reason to be on Zoom.
You can just record that as a video
and make it a more available.
So that's my general advice.
Leadership advice broadly,
I am on a journey myself
to learn a lot there, but
I'm a big believer that
the more that you can be authentic,
be your true self the more that you can,
I think sometimes people say,
"Oh, I have to be careful
what I need to say,
"because it might come off the wrong way.
"And so therefore I can't be authentic."
But what I found is you gotta
be careful what you think
and if you're thinking good thoughts,
if you're thinking
thoughts that would pass,
let's call it the New York Times test,
which is if your thoughts were published
in the New York Times,
would it be a good thing or bad thing?
If you can get your mind
to the point of like,
you're genuinely thinking good thoughts,
you're thinking of what
is best for others.
We all have thoughts every now and then
that we're not proud of.
I've had my sheriff but isn't,
you have a little process.
We were like, that's not a good thought.
That's yeah, that was a petty thought
or that was a thought, that
thought was driven by your ego
and not what's best for other folks.
If you can get good at that,
then I think that liberates you
to be very authentic with your leadership
because you are thinking things
that you're not ashamed of.
You know, someone I met when they said,
the best way to look like
you care about people
is to actually care about people.
So that's a little bit of a
little bit of a hack in life.
So I would say yeah, I
would say there's that.
And you know, always being
able to balance that tension
between what your heart tells you is right
and what your head tells
you is a reasonable approach
to being able to get there.
You know, throughout the last 10, 12 years
of this Khan Academy journey,
we've always had these debates
inside of the organization
of like, okay, we know that
there's that mountain someplace
that we want to get to the top of,
that's a world in which literally billions
of people have access to a
free world class education.
Now we, there's a fog.
We don't know exactly how to get there
and we'll just try to follow the gradient
and work our way through that fog
to the top of that mountain.
And we're gonna we're
going to make mistakes,
but you really have to do is say, "okay,
sometimes your heart might make you want
to go directly for that mountain,
but there might be a pit between,
so you're not gonna be
able to go to the mountain.
So your head has to say, no,
we got to go a hundred meters
to the right and cross
that bridge over there.
The other thing I would say is,
it's a lot like a chess game.
A good chess player doesn't know exactly
how they're going to
win the game in the end,
but they are definitely
setting up their board
so that they have as much
optionality as possible
and they have as much
protection as possible.
So they're getting their pieces out there,
opening it up, they're trying to control
the center of the board.
And so I'd say leadership
or strategy generally,
that's a good way to think about it.
You're never going to have
the whole thing figured out,
but never let the perfect
be the enemy of the good.
Anyway, I'll get off my soap box.
I don't know if that's useful at all.
- So Sal, you've been a
wonderful teaching role model
for folks and you've actually created
wonderful role models as well.
So I wanted to share this tweeted video
from Shanita731 and the tweet says,
"My daughter making our own
videos using Mr. Khan's voice
"about doing her kinder math packet.
"So thanks for the fun
practice and instruction."
Definitely pick and you play the video.
- [Phillipe] So here we have our five,
I'm gonna use this color
to circle my five
and then you minus,
we minus four.
So here's our four, we can
use blocks to circle four.
And so I want you to pause the video
to work it out
with a partner.
- [Dan] Thanks, Phillipe.
- [Phillipe] Okay, you got that.
- [Dan] So I wanted to
thank all the people
who are submitting and tweeting
and please send your messages
and we continue to enjoy
them and share them.
- Well, I think my earlier
comment about Khan Academy
being a multi generational institution,
I think we found my replacement.
It's surprised she's got the colors down.
She's making us pause the video
and try to enter it ourselves.
She's, I think Shanitta is onto something.
So don't be surprised if in a few years
we see more videos from
her, that's, that's great.
- Awesome, and then the question from--
- Go ahead.
- I wouldn't say we have a
question from an Angel Chopra
on YouTube and she asks,
"What courses would you recommend
"to take as an eighth
grader who wants to take
"more advanced classes,
that will push him?"
- Yeah, Angel, I would say you know
there was a previous question around
how much an eighth grader
could study, et cetera.
I mean I would, math is foundational
for a lot of things.
So I would keep going on Khan
Academy as far as you can go.
If you're comfortable with
seventh, eighth grade,
go on to algebra, go on to
algebra two, go on to geometry.
That's going to give
you a good foundation.
I think you're really
looking to push yourself.
You can start going into a lot of
the high school sciences
biology and chemistry.
You probably already have enough math
to tackle at least most of those subjects
at least at the kind of a
first year high school level.
And then physics, once you've learned
the basics of a little bit,
and this is probably
beyond where you are now,
if you're in middle
school are low, who knows?
But once you get the basics of quadratics
and some of the basics of trigonometry,
you can also think
about going into physics
and other humanity side,
we have a lot of content
on civics and American
history and world history.
I think you're, especially
if you're looking
to kind of push yourself,
you're probably already
ready for that material,
and our official SAT practice
actually could be interesting as well.
That's math, reading and writing.
And what a lot of folks don't realize
people normally take the SAT
and their junior or senior
years of high school,
but a lot of that content is essentially
at a middle school level.
They actually, the highest math on the SAT
is some of the more basic
concepts from algebra two,
which a lot of folks
cover in, in 10th grade.
But most of the math on the SAT is stuff
that you will see in
eighth or ninth grade.
And if you're trying to get ahead,
you're probably gonna see
that a little bit earlier.
So that'd be by my best advice there.
So let's see, other questions
I see here on YouTube,
Levy Corpio says,
"What was the last fun thing you have done
"with your child or with my children?"
Let's see, we do a lot of silly dancing.
I know a lot of y'all are thinking style.
There's no way you dance silly.
You must dance incredibly well
but I dance a little silly sometimes.
So we, we do a lot of that, and yeah,
that was the last one thing.
I mean, it was, it was
kind of dance hybrid
with wrestling on the carpet last night.
I think that was the most
recent fun thing we did.
And let's see, Anthony
Bombardier Devais says,
"What's your favorite book?"
Well, I'll give favorite books.
So I'll give some books
that play into my stereotype
because I've talked to them a lot.
I've talked a lot about science fiction
and whether benevolent aliens
are leveraging Khan Academy
to prepare humanity for first contact.
And in that stereotypical Sal the books
that I really have enjoyed are things like
Isaac Asimov's "Foundation series".
I've often talked about that series
as being something of an
inspiration for Khan Academy
that it takes place in a future
where someone is trying to
collect the world's knowledge
to shorten a galactic dark
ages by thousands of years.
I've always enjoyed "Diamond Age".
It gets a little edgy,
it's a little bit cyber punk at parts,
but I've liked the idea.
The story it's not
necessarily my favorite,
but I'd like the message which is
by giving these orphans who live on barges
and some dystopian future,
access to a free world
class education online.
They're able to take over the world.
I really like Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy.
I could go through all my
favorite science fiction books,
Dune, Childhood's End,
Arthur C. Clark, 2001,
Arthur C. Clark, so those
are all incredible books.
The general theme is
it's about, these are,
what codes you manage to become
either for better or for worse.
I think books that people
might not expect me to enjoy.
I think my faith "Pride and
Prejudice" is definitely
one of my all time favorite books.
I'm a big Mark Twain fan as well.
Most of his books, but something about
"Connecticut Yankee in
King Arthur's Court".
I really enjoyed because once again,
it's about someone who gets transported
from the industrial revolution
to "King Arthur's Court"
and by educating a new generation
of what other would be
kind of medieval children
they're able to help elevate what goes on.
And here we see a list of books
that children will not want to put down.
So feel free to look
at those those as well.
And there's a, there's
a ton of other books
that I'm sure I'm forgetting
that I really, really enjoy reading.
- [Dan] SO Sal, this is a reading list.
This is a reading list
that the staff put together
for a group by different age groups.
So these are a list from the staff
and recommendations from the staff.
- And these are available,
correct me if I'm wrong,
from our schedules and
we have the keep learning
about Khan Academy at Oregon.
People go there, you
dig around a little bit,
you should find all of
these types of resources
that we're talking about.
So let's see, there's other sub receive.
We have a from YouTube
Sattvic Agarwal says,
"Hey, tell how did you
learn so many subjects
"at such great depth?
"What is your secret
to studying anything?"
So the secret is to enjoy it.
And when you enjoy it and
you're viewing yourself,
you're not viewing yourself as like,
"Oh, I got to memorize this
thing for tomorrow's test.
"So that I don't feel."
If you do it that way, it's not
gonna nothing is pleasurable
if you do it that way.
But if you say, wow,
there is this knowledge
that for the last thousands of years
humanity has been collecting
and I have access to it
and I get to ponder the
connections between the knowledge.
I think for example, sometimes
things like textbooks,
they have, they give you the knowledge
but they don't connect the dots
with things you already know.
And so I think it's actually
a fun exercise to ponder.
I'm actually, that's the
favorite parts of my job now is
if I'm trying to teach organic
chemistry for me to say,
"So how does this mechanism connect to
"what we learned before?
"How are there some general themes here
"that the book is saying?"
and what you find is when you
ponder it for a little bit
and just ask people questions,
some of those connections for them
and you get to be a
little bit of a detective.
I view almost everything
on Khan Academy and beyond
as we're trying to understand this mystery
that we find ourselves
in called called life
and the universe, and as human beings,
I don't think there's
anything more fulfilling
than trying to make sense of that.
And yes, sometimes some of the ways
that we get exposed to
some of the mysteries,
whether it's in textbooks or other ways,
it might be a little bit cryptic,
but that's fun too.
You know, when you watch
a protagonist in a movie
and they come up with some hieroglyphics,
they don't just say, "Oh,
this is hard to read.
"I'm going to give up and
go do something else."
And I'm like, this is exciting.
This is an adventure.
When Harry Potter discovers
a spell book or whatever,
it's not like they just give up.
They're like, "How do we read this thing?
"How does this connect to other things?"
So I kind of view learning that way.
And I have found a lot of folks say,
"Oh, I'm a math person, or
I'm a humanities person."
I actually think if you
stereotype yourself in that way,
you're doing yourself an injustice.
And I've been guilty of it myself.
Early on in my life,
I didn't view myself as someone
who really enjoyed writing,
but now I do.
And the way that I kind
of made that transition
is to realize that,
when I was writing just to
try to impress someone else
just to try to get a grade,
I wasn't enjoying it that much.
But when I realized that writing
is really just a way
to get my point across,
to communicate something or
to express my imagination,
then all of a sudden it
became super exciting
and it's not one of my
favorite activities to write
or to communicate in other ways.
So I think it's all about
a mindset to realize
that very few people
are either math people
or writing people or humanities people.
Once you're used to learning any subject,
you can apply that, that same muscle
to almost everything else
and see the beauty in it.
So there's Scott Yang says,
"Wants us to extend our these
live streams to an hour each."
Well, that's tempting as you can imagine.
I am actually an introverted person,
but I obviously once y'all
get me on my soapbox,
I do keep going.
But I think for everyone, sustainability,
we'll try to keep them as close
to 30 minutes as possible,
but every now and then we might,
we're lining up some guests
over the next few weeks
that I think we'll,
we'll try to talk to them
as long as we can keep them going.
So, let's see.
There's other questions here
from a YouTube Nickel Govendor,
"Who's your favorite superhero?"
So not having thought about it
more than the last five seconds.
I have had an affinity to,
I think Batman's interesting
because he kind of has a
growth mindset about things
like he is not born
with any innate ability
but he leverages the
resources he does have.
And I guess he, well, he
was born with resources
according to the Batman legend.
But he's focused on improving himself
and becoming much stronger
than whatever innate
abilities he might have.
So I think there's something
very powerful about that,
but I'm sure I'm forgetting
many other superheroes
that are quite compelling.
So, Anjani asking another question.
"What's advice you would give to students
"who are stressed about the situation?"
The best thing to
realize is, first of all,
you're not alone, that's
helped me sometimes
when I started getting a little worried
about certain family members
who might be living by
themselves or they have a cough.
All of a sudden I'm like,
Oh no do they have COVID?
Is that we're all in this together.
And all you can do in life generally
to quote "Frozen 1" and "Frozen 2" is,
if you can't control a
situation to kind of let it go,
don't try to think too much about it.
If it's out of your sphere of control
and of the things that are
in your sphere of control,
do the next right thing.
And then the chips fall where they do.
In Vedic philosophy, there's
this notion of action.
There's a Rajasic action where
you're focused on the outcome
and then there's Sattvic action, which is,
in Sanskrit, it's truthful action
which is you're doing it
just because it's the right thing to do
regardless of what the outcome is.
And I think a lot of our stress in life,
a lot of our anxiety in life,
a lot of our suffering in life
happens because we get
attached to outcomes.
We're like, "Oh, that
thing has to happen."
And then, "Oh, what if it doesn't happen?"
And then you start
procrastinating, you get stressed,
you get anxious about it.
But if you just say, look,
none of us have control
over the universe, over this world,
all we can do is just the next right thing
and we do the next right thing
and just accept wherever the chips fall
is one way to keep moving forward
and doing the right thing
without getting overwhelmed.
The other thing I would recommend
is things like meditation exercise.
These are great ways to steal your mind,
to get your mind out of
some of the thought patterns
that a lot of folks
experiencing right now.
I would recommend minimize
watching the news.
You know, most of us know what's going on.
It doesn't hurt to watch
for 20 minutes a day
or something like that.
Say, okay, that's what's going on there.
That's what the government's doing.
But I think if you watch too much of it,
the news is almost designed to keep you
in this state of anxiety and the state of
that we this get your cortisol level up.
That normally only happens in nature
when a bear is chasing you,
which doesn't happen too often
if you were just wandering the forest.
But it's good for ratings
cause it gets you engaged.
But it could be bad
for your mental health.
So I would say spend as much time outside
exercising time with family,
stay connected through video conferencing
to friends and family,
meditate as much as you can
and also remind yourself
don't get caught up with stuff
that is out of your sphere of control
just stay within your sphere of control
and say, "What's the
next right thing I can do
"and feel good about that?"
So we are at time
Scott or we're not gonna go an hour today,
although maybe in the future,
but these were great questions.
I really enjoyed it,
Dan, thanks for bringing
in some of this is our
first time every day
we're trying a few new bells
and whistles Philippe's
in the background figuring out new ways
that we can leverage this tool
that we're doing to live stream.
But I really enjoy this and
thanks for everyone for joining.
This is a way for all
of us to stay connected.
And just as a reminder,
we are not for profit
and if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
Thanks everyone.